if you're a fan of classic adventure
games there's an incredible easter egg
in the PlayStation 4 game uncharted 4 a
thief's end about halfway through the
game Nathan Drake stumbles on a puzzle
in a pirate's lair he has to match up
portraits of pirates with their unique
insignias or sigils to solve the puzzle
nearing the end he discovers that the
names of some of the Pirates in the
portraits have been burned away and that
there's a sigil a monkey that he can't
identify nah see there Sully turns out
Sam doesn't know everything either let's
just look at the paintings don't
recognize this guy
looks a lot younger than the other
pirates at some point as you're staring
at these paintings trying to make sense
of it all you realize that you're
looking right at none other than guy
brush Threepwood hero of the LucasArts
classic Monkey Island adventure game
series this should be no surprise as
uncharted 4 co-creator Neil druckmann
says that Monkey Island 2 is one of his
top 3 games of all time but the Monkey
Island references don't stop there later
as Nate continues his quest to find the
lost pirate city of Liberty Lea this
happens that is the second biggest
sister and I have ever seen it was the
biggest I'll tell you later come on
let's get down there
now Uncharted fans know that Drake has
indeed encountered bigger cisterns in
previous games but this too is a Monkey
Island reference that's the second
biggest blank I've ever seen is a
running gag in the classic series we do
see guy brush one last time before the
game's end his skeleton anyway sitting
around a table with his fellow pirates
poisoned to death with his monkey sigil
right by his side